hello and welcome to the new world of
your source for everything anime and
manga that anime and or manga being as
it often is hunter hunter because today
we are back with a rather big task
counting down the top 10 antagonists of
the series tough because hunter hunter
is one of those stories
absolutely packed with well-built
characters each of whom explore
radically different ideas
so that in turn does make them very hard
to compare even if we are just isolating
that to antagonists but of course we are
going to do our best anyway just as you
should do your best to casually wander
over to the subscribe button for the new
order view and
press it thus resulting in regular hunt
hunt content uploaded straight into your
youtube feed oh and one more thing i
should maybe mention is that it was
going to be pretty hard to put something
like this together without considering
the manga material that has yet to be
animated so to the anime only watches
you may see a few new faces and i guess
proceed at your own risk and is if you
don't want to be spoiled for the
eventual 2040
animated series of hunter hunter because
seriously it's not coming back anytime
soon so you may as well know what you're
missing but with that we shall commence
with antagonist number 10
illumi zoldick and starting out with a
predominantly calm and collected
assassin illemi's seemingly lack of any
emotion whatsoever very much sets him
apart in a world where the power system
is driven almost directly by
raw need and desire so amongst all of
that illumi exists as a beacon of
consistency
and professionalism taking no real
pleasure from his actions which is going
to be quite a rare feature on this list
however what does make killing me all
the more terrifying is that underneath
all this and i mean buried very
very deeply there is an insatiable lust
for power dominance and control which
really only comes into focus during one
brief moment of the series where he is
thinking about his desire to control
alaka's power never before
and never again which makes enemy
something of a great mystery he is not
to be taken lightly in any sense
anytime he appears it signals extreme
danger to me as a reader or watcher of
the series
and while he is a pretty damn fantastic
antagonist i do wish we got to see a bit
more of him although the manga is
currently providing quite a bit of
promise in that regard provided
that it ever continues that is but as
for a much more well-rounded and more
explored antagonist let's head to number
nine who will be uvagine a much more
classical presence in every sense
uvagine initially presented himself as
quite a stereotypically big brawling guy
thing
not the smartest but that's okay because
he can do you know the punching better
than you can that impression would
change quite quickly though as uvagine
and in fact the entirety of the phantom
troupe were given a level of
humanization not typically extended to
a group of genocidal maniacs and as a
result overgain is a very conflicting
existence i both love and hate him which
is great because that sort of dichotomy
makes him fascinating and
attention-grabbing and although his run
in the series was quite brief he does
provide one of the most memorable pieces
of action with his fight against
karapika as well as kind of leaves this
world as the hero of his own story
refusing to acquiesce to krapika's
demands and choosing death
over the idea of selling out his fellow
troop members it's quite sickeningly
touching to watch over against demise
and it always leaves me with this
horrible aftertaste for karapika as if
he's the one who's kind of the
antagonist which is not true but that's
how it feels and i think that's the mark
of a
very very well done job from mr uvagine
now for someone who may not have done
such a good job we have number eight
gyro and when i say that i mean that he
hasn't done such a good job
yet however anytime we mention gyro i do
need to do the standard explanation
which is that in the anime an
extraordinarily important part was cut
out of the chimera ant arc and that was
when
gyro was shown alive after having been
converted into chimera ant and
sinisterly strolling through the very
same city that both gon and kilwa were
present in and currently it's believed
that gyro is in meteor city however the
reason why he is on this list is because
he presents
quite possibly the greatest potential
threat that this series has ever known
and this is because during his flashback
we saw that gyro was an individual who
had cast aside his humanity
long before becoming a chimera ant and
his sole goal in life is now simply to
disseminate evil throughout the world
and his tenacity for this evil is so
strong that it allowed him to easily
break free of the ant queen's control
and retain his human memories
so now with his new body and the
potential of nenus which as we know
responds directly to desire
gyro is very much the ultimate
antagonist just waiting to rock this
world and the only reason why he's this
far down on the list is because we've
only seen the briefest of glimpses of
that however that one glimpse is more
than enough to land him at number eight
more manga specific stuff now as we head
into number seven with beyond netara a
man who inherited almost 100
of his aesthetics from his father isaac
nataro along with what is hinted to be
an astonishing level of power and a
startling amount of charisma however
beyond puts these traits to use in a
much more outwardly antagonistic way
than his father ever did and at this
very moment beyond is almost
single-handedly spearheading the plot to
travel to the dark continent
a location that he has already been to
on one occasion mind you which speaks
pretty tremendously to his capabilities
something that is quite underrated
regarding beyond though is his mental
prowess he is a man who has managed to
outwit
each and every one of the zodiacs within
the hunter association as well as entire
structures of power such as the kakin
empire or the v5 nations
and essentially resulting in beyond
having managed to manipulate every
primary source of political power in the
human realm simply to achieve his own
highly mysterious dark continent-related
goals
which whatever they are they are not
good this man is the embodiment of
sinister and right now it's really
difficult to think of anyone who would
be able to stop him so to turn away from
that impending disaster let's all focus
on number six being hisoka and honestly
compared to every other antagonist we've
explored thus far and will continue to
explore hisoka really doesn't compare in
terms of motivation he's just a morally
ambiguous clown magician out there to do
nothing but satisfy his own lust for
combat
and that makes him so consistently
inconsistent hisoka is an antagonist who
is capable of assuming any role in story
he can serve as the main antagonist as
he effectively did during the hunter
exam in heaven's arena but he can also
be a supporting character like york new
city or even a protagonist himself like
on greed island but the important thing
here is that we
as an audience never quite know how this
is going to pan out it's very hard to
predict which hisokui will be served and
as such despite the fact that his
actions are you know
less world shaking than others his
strong history within the series and
continued menace absolutely makes him
one of the most fearsome antagonists
that hunter hunter has to offer but
speaking of fearsome i think that one
antagonist that really embodies that
word would be our number five
nephipito from the moment that pito
first stepped into the series hunter
hunter was hit with a wave of
unstoppable primal force
in fact i would actually describe pito
as a hisoka just with a goal that is not
entirely selfish
which in my eyes makes pito far far more
dangerous
when it comes down to it peter will do
anything and everything for the sake of
the ant king and they'll have a hell of
a lot of fun doing it as well which of
course
includes wild amounts of sadistic
torture hurrah pepito also comes
equipped with other troubling qualities
such as an effectively unlimited
quantity of aura and an affinity of
specialization which putting the two
together means that pito is capable of
accomplishing anything and
everything that they please very much
disturbing the balance of the nen power
system by putting the unlimited aura
cheat on but of course beta also comes
with a deep emotional connection as an
antagonist due to the whole kite killing
fiasco an action that would eventually
result in our main protagonist gone
being removed from the focus of the
series altogether so really when you
think about it that's a pretty stunning
endorsement of peter an antagonist that
really did put an end to our main
character with that said hunter hunter
has a fair bit more to offer including
our number four crolo lucifer so
initially he has the whole stoic silent
illumi vibe about him except that crollo
is demonstrably more driven
as the leader of the phantom troop
crawler has command over one of the
single most powerful group of
individuals on the planet and he puts
them to pretty phenomenal use because
crawler is what i would describe
as utility combatant on his own he does
not present power in a classical sense
and his danger mainly comes from his
ability to analyze and strategize which
is of course very well reflected in his
non-ability skill hunter allowing him to
steal the abilities of others but only
after fulfilling a truly ridiculous
amount of conditions that only someone
of crolo level genius would be able to
pull off and as such with the right
amount of planning i firmly believe that
crolo could defeat anyone
something that was demonstrated in the
manga in his very one-sided fight
against hisoka in heaven's arena however
this also highlights a great weakness
because crollo is far less adept at
improvised combat without a
well-formulated strategy he is quite
vulnerable but then again
only to really top tnn users with plenty
of time for strategy though crollo
may as well be invincible maybe
invincible depends who is going up
against that is because there are other
incredibly sharp minds in the series and
one of the most finely tuned would be
our number three pariston hill and i
have never been more terrified by a
character that we know next to nothing
about
than i have with paristan every time he
appears on screen or on page he makes me
very very nervous and for good reason as
well because you can never quite dissect
paristan's goals or feelings even when
he has inner monologues because they
generally leave me with more
questions and answers and just an
overwhelming takeaway of no one
no one ever should be around this man he
is an unequivocal danger to everyone and
everything and this happy facade will
always instill more fear into me than
even the creepiest expressions of
someone like pito hisoko or illumi
none of them have anything on this
terrifyingly happy man
with that said if i had to choose i
would much rather be around paristan
than our number two contender
fourth prince charadnick because of all
of the monsters that togashi has
conjured sradnik would be the most
concerning as he really does push the
desires of humanity far beyond any
reasonable limits and really kind of
crosses over into the territory of being
demonic i mean his hobbies are the kind
of things that we would see happening in
like a 15th century painting of hell and
that's because saradnik has by far the
scariest hobby of all
which is art and humans are merely
supplies for said art and perhaps that
wouldn't be so bad on its own however in
addition to this radnic just so happens
to be quite possibly the greatest
natural net genius that we've ever
casually stumbled across
easily eclipsing the talon to both gon
and kilauea who were both said to have a
one in ten million talent and if that is
indeed the metric we're going by then
saradnick would easily be one in a
billion aura control just comes so
naturally to him that before even having
mastered the basics of nen he had
already unconsciously summoned his onan
beast as well as developed a separate
hatsu that allows him to see briefly
into the future oh and he is of course a
specialist which always makes things
much
much worse if left unchecked for a few
more days let alone weak support the
blackwell one
i have no doubt that sradnik will become
one of the greatest nin users in the
world which will signal the beginning of
a very dark age for those within his
wide reaching radius but still it is
very difficult to crown him as the
ultimate antagonist given that we do
have
number one the ant king meruem the
literal antagonist if you will
although to be fair i also could have
made that joke with both pito and gyro
but i
saved it for the king because i really
cannot do this character any degree of
justice in a short explanation like this
but for a creature who began life as an
overpowered cell rip-off he developed
into one of the most compelling
presences in this
and indeed any other series meroem is an
antagonist so well written
that it generally makes me question
whether we were on the right side during
the chimera antarctic and whether or not
the world would actually be a better
place perhaps even as close as we could
come to a utopia with him in charge
he was simultaneously fear-inducing and
yet incredibly empathetic
to the point where it was tragic to see
him depart existence because he had
learnt so much more and come so much
further in 40 days than the entire human
race had in their long long history and
so to me
marowan will always be the greatest
antagonist and quite possibly arguably
even the greatest protagonist of hunter
hunter but what do you guys think please
do leave your thoughts in the comments
below or even join my discord server and
if you're keen for some more hand toned
content then please do go and check out
some of my other videos or even
subscribe to the channel for regular
hunt hunter glory delivered straight
into your youtube feed but for now this
has been the new world review
and i'll see you next time